DeSANTIS FLEW MIGRANTS WHO WILL
NOT IN HIS STATE TO BEGIN WITH.
SO, LET ME JUST SHOW YOU WHAT WE
KNOW THAT THE MIGRANTS INVOLVED
WITH THESE FIRST TWO FLIGHTS TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD HAD CROSSED
THE UNITED STATES BORDER INTO
TEXAS, AND THAT IS WHERE
DeSANTIS' TWO PRIVATE PLANES
PICK THEM UP.
SO THEN THEY WERE FIRST FLOWN TO
FLORIDA.
IT WAS A QUICK STOP THERE.
AND THEN ONE PLANE STOP TO NORTH
CAROLINA, THE OTHER IN SOUTH
CAROLINA.
AND FINALLY BOTH WENT ON TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
NOW WHEN I SHOW THIS, THIS IS A
LOT WE KNOW.
WE DON'T KNOW THESE REASONS, WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THESE STRANGE
FLIGHT PATHS.
BUT THIS POLITICAL MOVE BY
DeSANTIS SHOULDN'T ACTUALLY HAVE
BEEN MUCH OF A SURPRISE BECAUSE
HE ACTUALLY HAS BEEN TELLING
PEOPLE ABOUT HIS PLAN FOR
MONTHS.
HERE'S DeSANTIS BACK IN DECEMBER
TALKING ABOUT WHAT HE THOUGHT
SHOULD BE DONE WITH UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS.
>> IT'S SOMEWHAT TONGUE AND
CHEEK, BUT IT IS TRUE.
IF YOU SENT TO DELAWARE OR
MARTHA'S VINEYARD OR SOME OF
THESE PLACES, THAT BORDER WOULD
BE SECURE THE NEXT DAY.
>> MARTHA'S VINEYARD OR SOME OF
THESE PLACES AND, YOU KNOW, TED
CRUZ TWEETED ABOUT IT, THIS WAS
COMING PEOPLE.
DeSANTIS AGAIN SPOKE OF HIS
PLANS TO A ROOM FULL OF DONORS
AT THE 4 SEASONS IN ORLANDO.
ACCORDING TO "THE WASHINGTON
POST," DeSANTIS SAID, QUOTE, I
DO HAVE THIS MONEY, I WANT TO BE
HELPFUL, MAYBE WE WILL GO TO
TEXAS AND HELP.
MAYBE WE'LL SEND TO CHICAGO,
HOLLYWOOD, MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
WHO KNOWS.
ROSA FLORES IS OUT FRONT IN SAN
ANTONIO, TEXAS.
THAT IS WHERE THE FLIGHTS OF
THESE MIGRANTS ORIGINATED.
I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO TALK TO
THESE PEOPLE TO SEE WHY THEY GOT
ON THESE FLIGHTS TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
>> Reporter: WE'VE ALSO BEEN
TRYING TO FIND THIS MYSTERY
WOMAN BY THE NAME OF PEARLA WHO
ALLEGEDLY RECRUITED ALL THESE
MIGRANTS TO GET ON THIS FLIGHT.
SO WE'VE RETRACED HER STEPS.
LET ME TAKE YOU THROUGH THIS
BECAUSE WHAT YOU SEE BEYOND THE
TREES, THAT'S THE MIGRANT
RESOURCE CENTER HERE IN SAN
ANTONIO.
AND WE'VE WATCHED THIS HAPPEN
ALL DAY LONG.
MIGRANTS CROSS THAT BUSY STREET
THAT YOU SEE BEHIND ME, AND THEY
GO TO THE SHOPPING CENTERS THAT
ARE ALL AROUND ME HERE.
NOW I'VE BEEN COLLABORATING WITH
MY COLLEAGUE BECAUSE SHE'S BEEN
GETTING PHOTOGRAPHS AND ALSO
VIDEOS OF THIS WOMAN NAMED
PEARLA AND THE STEPS THAT THEY
TOOK ALONG THE WAY.
WE'VE BEEN RECONNECTING SOME OF
THOSE DOTS.
AND TURNS OUT THIS IS THE
PARKING LOT WHERE THIS WOMAN
PEARLA MET WITH ALL OF THESE
MIGRANTS.
AND, REMEMBER, THIS IS THE WOMAN
WHO PROMISED THESE MIGRANTS THAT
THEY WERE GOING TO HAVE SHELTER
AND ALSO A JOB WHENEVER THEY GOT
TO THEIR FINAL DESTINATION.
NOW RIGHT NOW YOU DON'T SEE A
LOT OF MIGRANTS HERE.
BUT TAKE A LOOK AT THIS VIDEO
BECAUSE WE WERE HERE ALL DAY
LONG EARLIER TODAY.
THERE WAS LOTS OF MIGRANTS HERE.
I WAS ABLE TO TALK TO THEM.
NO ONE HAD SEEN PEARLA.
NO ONE KNEW ABOUT PEARLA.
THEY'RE ONLY ALLOWED TO STAY FOR
THREE DAYS AT THIS MIGRANT
CENTER.
NOBODY HAD HEARD OF PEARLA.
BUT WE KEPT ON RETRACING HER
STEPS.
TURNS OUT THESE MIGRANTS WERE
TRANSPORTED ABOUT 17 MILES
SOUTHWEST OF THIS LOCATION TO A
HOTEL.
WE'VE GOT VIDEO OF THIS.
WE ASKED PEOPLE AT THIS HOTEL IF
THEY KNEW ABOUT PEARLA.
THEY HAD NOT.
BUT, AGAIN, WE HAVE PICTURES AND
VIDEO TO PROVE THAT THAT'S WHERE
THE MIGRANTS WERE.
THE MIGRANTS STAYED THERE FOR
ABOUT FIVE DAYS.
AFTER THAT THEY WERE TRANSPORTED
ABOUT FIVE MILES EAST TO JOINT
BASE SAN ANTONIO TO KELLY FIELD.
THAT'S WHERE THAT PLANE LEFT TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
SO, ERIN, DID WE FIND PEARLA?
NO, WE DID NOT FIND PEARLA.
BUT, AS YOU KNOW, GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS IS TAKING CREDIT FOR
ALL OF THIS.
SO I ASKED HIS PRESS SECRETARY.
I HAVE NOT HEARD BACK.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE TALKING HERE,
ERIN, ARE THE MIGRANTS, THE MANY
MIGRANTS WE TALKED TO HERE, AND
WHAT THEY SAY IS THEY ARE ANGRY,
THEY ARE UPSET FOR WHAT HAPPENED
TO THESE MIGRANTS BECAUSE WHAT
THEY TOLD ME IS THESE MIGRANTS